STEVEN HALL: The first
problem is right here.
I'm going to give you
a chance to practice
doing a proportional
derivative controller.
And I've actually written
the specifications directly
in terms of phase margin
and crossover frequency.
So you can either
imagine that that's
the way the
specifications are given
or that we started with a
rise time and peak overshoot
and derived these.
So your goal is to
design a k of s that
meets these specifications.
So if everyone could please,
form up in groups of two
around the room as usual.
I'm Steve Hall,
I'm the instructor
of 1606, which is Principles
of Automatic Control.
It's a junior level
classical control
class, which I've been
teaching for about six years.
So recitations in 1606 are
a little different than most
recitations at MIT.
In most recitations,
the instructor
would present a series
of problems maybe related
to the homework, just
to give examples of how
the problem should be worked.
Sometimes they might have
students try some themselves.
In my recitations,
it's much more active.
Students are always standing
up, we work at the board,
usually in groups of two.
So there might be
10 groups of two
spread around the
room, each group of two
working at a board.
A blackboard, a whiteboard,
could be a poster board.
They're working
problems and the TA
and I are walking around
and helping when we can,
answering questions
when students
have them, and
generally just coaching,
trying to help the students
understand what they're doing
and solve the problems.
It really is a
chance for students
to understand what they know
and what they don't know
and to exercise the skills that
they've learned in the class.
And if they have problems
with those skills,
it's a chance for me to
help them learn them better.